salut scellé la volks extrêmement fort
en bresse et justice c'est toujours faux
aujourd'hui je suis avec yann en chair
et en os avec un petit synthé 1 1 pour
faire de la musique
on va créer une musique avec vous avec
avec faux pas mais on va faire fureur la
fin à ces partis début la leçon la
mélodie principale c'est parti d'une
petite idée étrange 17 ans et peut-être
que j'aime ordre tandis que lui et donc
on part sur un saxo sur un saxo alto on
est parti sur ceux ci y voilà c'est joli
j'aime beaucoup et c'est bien ça va pas
mal chez nous en même temps donc je sais
nous ça nous représente chez que michael
est plus voilà non ici c'est génial
parce que les gens à vendre ses deux ont
vu ils ont vu les vidéos de wax depuis
nos vins là il arrive là il faut mais
qu'est-ce qu'on drôle avec ses deux
polonais c'est ça qu'on aime on a opté
pour un tempo 1 100 ppm conduire une
mesure classique en binaire du 4 4
tout simplement
on va tout simplement recalés mais tu
insinue que je n'ai pas fait ça dans les
temps non c'est une en train de manière
que si on avait été réservé pas qu'on va
durer un jour on s'est embrouillé à roy
je me casse je ferme à notre groupe qui
s'appelle justice et l'annoncé tout
droit
c'est fantastique leçon est terminée
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
la boîte à rythme est ce que c'est pas
un petit peton rayons effectivement je
vais pas te cacher que bon j'ai fait
beaucoup de batteries étant jeune plus
maintenant mais il me reste quelques
balles alors qu'elles sont nous as tu
trouvé parfaitement est pour l'instant
voté pour l'instant aucun nom un fait et
ce qu'on parque sur un truc électro ou
est ce qu'on essaie de se rapprocher
plus d'une vraie batterie ou préférer la
bataille etc trop la batterie acoustique
et tu mets ça sur twitter tout de suite
on fait ça merci pour votre aide
merci à tous et merci à tous pour votre
a fait vraiment su faire plaisir à
quelqu'un préfère la batterie externe
apparemment voit la chance était perdre
aux matons carstens à départager un
jailbreak tu nous fasses une black city
va très bien ce sont deux prostituées et
elle se dispute
tu l'as ou d'un oui vous l'avez aussi
ça s'est départagé on est maintenant à
824 vote et 53% pour la batterie
acoustique c'est parti à nous c'est au
domaine fait nous vibrer
hadorn notamment le début de mes trucs
et s'y attendre est totalement le début
de la dh 3 de large sont de votre guide
rien mais qu à aa
ça ressemble et là on aime en maître
gims ne se trompe pas elle vidéo non moi
ce qui me fait surtout mal c'est je suis
d'avoir foutu mes trucs là encore
c'était plus dit pas y compris et m'a
chauffé branche de notes je m'en vais je
me faire un tri yann tu dis quoi des
gens qui boivent du thé déjà bons qu'ils
ont une orientation sexuelle un peu
différente des hétéros mais c'est tout
donc là on est parti sur deux mesures et
ensuite la boîte à rythmes rentrer à la
3e 9e sur nous dans l'à-peu-près
simple efficace tous en l'air yann peux
tu nous faire écouter le saxo en plus de
la boîte à rythmes bien évidemment
je suis clark kent et j'approuve ce beat
là j'ai su remettre comme ça on est
parti avec le métronome bien sûr mercian
pour cette petite basse
voilà ça c'est le mal de tout musicien
tu commences à écouter à réécouter à ré
ré ré ré écouter ton truc que tu dis
c'est vraiment de la merde
si je peux me permettre à diéval cher m
tu me retrouve est-ce que dès la
première écoute
il n'y avait pas déjà cette impression
de la boucle ce truc pour saxo pendant
la coupe de la canne qui avait un
problème avec ce sac seau qui veut
également énerve absolument tout le
monde s'émeut les oreilles on trouve le
son qui va bien avec ce rythme
arrêtez arrêtez l'exorciser des gens
avec cette chanson en font
oh
ça fait très longtemps on a fini on a
fait un truc bien à tour pris de a à f
ce n'est pas fait grand chose et c'est
bien là on a tombé d'aidé bonne
rythmique tu prêt à balancer sa ba soyez
indulgents ça reste un truc un peu pété
je pensais passer un premier c'est un
premier jet je te laisse l'honneur de
lancer le son c'est parti 3 4 c'est la
fin de notre chanson arnaque
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça vous a pu
apercevoir la chaîne de yann petit
teasing
on fera une deuxième vidéo de juin à
ricaner ses copains musiciens pour faire
un son encore mieux que celui là merci
d'avoir gardé avons tous une prochaine
vidéo c'était daft punk au revoir urines